the death toll has risen to at least 10
after falling after a falling tree
killed two people in Beaumont first
responders in Houston say they've
rescued more than 13,000 people the
mayor has ordered a midnight to 5:00
a.m. curfew Nora is in downtown Houston
once again outside the Convention Center
handling an overflow crowd where you
give us such a good view of that
yesterday Nora good morning hey good
morning t Maurice you know the mayor of
Houston said yesterday that conditions
will improve inside this shelter and he
was right they made changes in fact the
conditions are improving this morning
inside that shelter now about 80 300
people stayed inside there that's about
a few thousand fewer than yesterday city
officials opened more downtown shelters
they're trying to relieve pressure here
mark Strassmann is inside mark good
morning
morning Nora that surge of evacuees that
overwhelmed this Convention Center for
city officials to open up to more big
shelters downtown and you're right that
should ease some of the pressure here
where volunteers have struggled to deal
with short supplies and short tempers
volunteers from across Texas scrambled
to convert Houston's NRG Center into a
shelter for storm victims right here
right now setting up cots for those
people that were not able to get into
some of the other shelters that were
open less than 24 hours after planning
for the shelter began evacuees started
pouring in the Center has made room for
up to ten thousand displaced residents
caring for these rescue victims has been
a logistical challenge for Houston mayor
Sylvester Turner can you guarantee that
the supply chains of food water cots are
going to get through to that Center in
time for these folks we have made a
request on FEMA for an additional 10,000
cots and additional supplies and we have
said that we need them to get here as
soon as possible
once again Turner defended his decision
not to evacuate nearly 7 million people
ahead of the storm are you satisfied
that that plan was the right plan the
hurricane did not hit the city of
Houston the city of Houston has been
impacted by an inordinate amount of rain
the things that you cannot avoid you
simply have to learn
and how to manage I'm going to allow all
the people on social media and talking
heads to talk but they don't have the
responsibility of managing or running
this city I do many safety experts agree
that decision was likely best given the
available information at the time
former FEMA official Elizabeth Zimmerman
anytime you can get people out of harm's
way ahead of time is safer for them in
disasters
the third shelter that has no opened is
the Toyota Center that's about a block
from here it's where the NBA Houston
Rockets play it's going to hold about
5,000 people families only no pets but
the logistical challenge Nora will stay
the same trying to get all the supplies
to all these families that need them for
their sustainable future
it is a logistical challenge mark thank
you so much